yeah
[Music]
[Music]
but of course they don't
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's a church
they're trying to go
[Music]
[Music]
we are doing the identification
all right so we waited basically time
because talk was announced more broadly
so it's a great pleasure to introduce
our journalists and residents Dana
Mackenzie who's here over the summer so
the the journalists in residence program
here has I guess two aims we're hoping
to support science journalism and
particularly journalists that write
about theoretical computer science but
we're also wanting to expose the program
participants here to experts in you know
communicating with with a broad audience
to help them out in in that direction
and this summer we have journalists in
residence for the first time we have a
journalist in residence over the summer
for the program that's running on
quantum computation and we're very
pleased that it's Dana Mackenzie so he's
a mathematics and science writer has a
number of books the big splat or how our
moon came to be the universe in zero
words and most recently is co-author
with pearl on the book of Y so an
account of causality that has just come
out last month I guess so
actually Dana is one of a bunch of
prizes and awards for his work and very
talking to us today about a conversation
about science communication welcome well
thank you for being here and I actually
do mean a conversation literally so
anytime you feel like like asking
questions or anything please feel free
to interrupt and I hope also there will
be plenty of time at the end for
questions and and talking further about
whatever inspires you so first of all
can everyone hear me okay right alright
so yeah so as Peter said I'm the
journalist in residence this summer and
at the end of this talk I'll say a
little bit about what I'd like to do I'd
like to contribute to to this program
and so I have a couple specific ideas
for doing that and those but first of
all I'd just like to give you a general
let's talk about my route into science
communication and things I learned from
it and things that may benefit other
people who are interested also in
writing for the public or communicating
with the public more broadly so I'll
start out telling about my story and how
I made this strange transition from
being a PhD mathematician to being a
freelance writer doesn't happen every
day so it's kind of an interesting story
and I definitely learned some
interesting things on way and then I'd
like to talk about how the people in
this audience might go about
communicating and writing and finally
gives I'll give some unsolicited advice
which you're free to ignore and then and
then we'll talk about at the very end my
ideas for what I could offer to you this
summer so so here's kind of a timeline
for my story and I actually got my PhD
in 83 and the beginning that the
timeline soar begins in 89 which was
when I
had to first go on the second time I
went on the job market after getting my
PhD and already then I was kind of
thinking about freelance writing as a
career option but not really sure how to
do it and and so and it turned out I
didn't have to because I got a job offer
and and so I was comfortably employed
for six more years after that but it is
very interesting to kind of look at some
of the that dipping my toe in phase and
anyway then in 1995 I was kind of forced
to jump in the pool because I had a
tenure decision that didn't go my way
and I don't know you guys are all pretty
young but in the mid 90s the job market
in mathematics was extremely bad and and
so I really knew I had no hope of being
able to get another academic job and so
then I started thinking about what else
could I do and of course I'd already
been thinking about writing and then so
the key like most important moment of my
life practically was finding out that
there is something called the science
communication program at the University
of California Santa Cruz this was and is
a unique program that takes people with
a degree in science okay you're required
to have a degree in some science and
then it teaches you the basics of
journalism and it really emphasizes
being employable so the people who it's
a one-year program the people who finish
the program do get jobs and they either
typically either work on staff for
magazines or newspapers or they work in
public information offices for
universities or government labs or some
like me become freelance writers so it
really has a terrific track record and
you'd be amazed at what a large
percentage of science writers in the
country are actual actually graduates of
the ECSC program sort of like our own
little mafia
okay so since 1997 I've been a freelance
writer so more than 20 years now a lot
of people when they you tell them that
they're that you're a writer they
immediately want to know what books
you've written so actually most of my
writing through my career has not been
books it's been magazines but
nevertheless writing books is a terrific
way to build name recognition and
credibility and has sort of more
permanence than than the magazine
writing so I'm glad to talk about my
three books I'll say a little bit about
each of them so certainly one of the
delights of choosing this career path is
you know that writing books is is a real
option and and they're books that people
might actually pick up in the bookstore
you know my sister just texted me two
days ago and said saw your book in the
airport told them to order more you know
so that's kind of fun so so let me back
up to this first when I was in late 80s
so my first dipping the toe in the water
so as I was thinking about writing the
not sure how to do it and so one idea
had was to send letters to all of the
well-known math writers I could think of
and ask them how they did it and if they
had any advice and this actually I'm
really glad I did this and one of the
things that amazed me is that every
single one of them wrote back you know
even though these are famous dudes and I
was I'm nobody you know I was just a
visiting assistant professor at Duke
University nevertheless they took time
to write back so this was to Martin
Gardner and I'm just curious how many
people here have heard of Martin Gardner
okay good if this were a math audience
it would be everybody at least everybody
over a certain age but for a computer
science audience and younger people
maybe not but Martin Gardner has a
column for for many years like 30 years
at least I think in the Scientific
American called mathematical games and
it was absolutely unique column is is is
where so many mathematicians in my
generation and even little after me
first we're exposed to the idea that
math is fun and that you can do math
just for because it's it's it's
interesting and that because it's
something you have to learn in school so
anyway I idolized Martin Gardner since I
was a kid so I wrote to him you know not
expecting to get an answer back but sure
enough he wrote back and he wrote some
great advice
so I highlighted a couple things here so
he said I think the best way to get into
journalism is to first place a few
articles so he thinks that's a good way
to to build up a little bit of
credibility before you try writing a
book so publishers are much more
inclined to take a proposal seriously if
you can send them sample articles then
another thing the second thing I
highlighted is very important very
practical advice and it's a big
difference between popular writing and
academic writing so he says a good plan
to first query the editor with a single
page letter asking him if you'd like to
see the piece you have in mind now in
academic writing as most or all of you
know you first write the paper and then
you send it to a journal that's not the
way popular writing works so in in
popular writing you first write a query
which is just no more than a page okay
and you send that to the editor so you
haven't written the article yet and as a
freelancer you would be wasting your
time if you wrote all your articles
before you before you tried to sell them
because not all of your pitches
especially if it's a cold pitch to
editor you don't know probably the
majority of your pitches will not be
successes and so you need to you don't
want to invest the time to write a full
article until you know that you're going
to be able to have it published and be
paid for it so so query writing query
letters is this huge difference between
popular writing and academic writing
another guy I wrote to was Ian Stewart
who also is a very well known math
writer who I read several of his books
and he wrote back too and there are some
great things here in his letter as well
the main message is do it I love that
and
you know a lot of times people think you
need some kind of special training or
qualification to be a writer and well I
am a person who went through a year and
UCSC so so I did have training but it's
feasible to do without the training and
so he's saying you know the best way to
become a writer is just to start writing
and you know even if you aren't
successful at first here still it's good
for your you know just for developing
your voice to to write a lot okay
especially when you're starting up and
don't be so worried about what whether
people will buy it or what they'll think
of it so then another thing he says here
the main thing is you need to have a
good story to tell and he underlines a
good story this is another big
difference between academic writing and
popular writing and popular writing you
the story comes first you always want
the article to be to tell the story and
in fact journalists will say I wrote a
story about so-and-so more often than
they'll say I wrote an article about
so-and-so I mean they're sort of
synonymous but I think it's really
interesting that the journalists used
the word story a lot because most
articles are told as a story that means
first of all they are about people so
that's a big difference when you write
academic articles they're often about
things you know they're about some
theorem you've proved in mathematics or
or some you know experiment you've done
in some other science so you're you're
reporting on a thing but when you write
for the public the people are paramount
and it's usually the people who did the
work so you know I will usually try to
tell the story the people I'm reporting
on and to some extent it may also be the
history behind the problem that you're
working on so how did this come to be
considered an important problem
what were the roadblocks and what is it
that this new work is trying to trying
to overcome but so when I when I'm
talking a story I am trying though to
emphasize the human side and he doesn't
he said it doesn't have to be dressed up
with human interest
that helps then he also says another
underline thing make the effort to make
it comprehensible in spirit but not in
fine detail this is again very hard for
academics and it's an attitude change
you have to make when you go from
academic writing to popular writing so
you have to be willing to tolerate some
inaccuracies you can't say everything
perfectly you know you can't be you
can't define all your terms exactly like
you do in a math article but you just
want to get across the main idea you may
have just one main idea in your article
that you want the audience to understand
and if they get that you should be happy
and you don't worry about whether they
understand you know the difference
between L 2 and H 2 or something like
that you know so so you have to have
more tolerance for for things that are
approximately correct and maybe that's
even harder for mathematicians than
other scientists I don't know because
mathematicians really appreciate precise
definitions anyway so a few years later
then I went to this science
communication program at UCSC and learn
many things let me say go over a few
these because I think they are very
useful for anyone not only anyone who
wants to do writing for the public but
also anyone who wants to understand why
is popular writing the way it is you
know what are journalists doing ok so so
one thing I learned is that there's lots
more to write about than mathematics so
I had gone into this sore thinking I'm
going to be a math writer but there
aren't really very many people who are
just math writers out there so it's much
easier if you're also willing to write
about other things and in fact as a
journalist it's really a must you have
to be a generalist and that's actually
one of the beautiful things about
journalism you know when I was in
college I hated that I had to declare a
major and just you know go into
mathematics because I like all my
subjects you know I'd like to English
and I liked history and
everything so unfortunately the academic
world forces you to specialize and
specialize and specialize but when you
go into to become a journalist you want
to generalize okay you get to write
about all sorts of things and I actually
think that in the academic world
eventually at a certain point
generalizing is good too I mean I think
the academics who do the best are the
ones who take the broad view but
definitely as a journalist you want to
be able to write about lots of things
and other important things turning
turning stories over really fast so as a
student at UCSC I did an internship in a
newspaper so typically I would come in
in the morning be given an assignment
and have to have the story written by
that evening so that is really a fast
time schedule and fortunately most of my
work is not done on anything near that
schedule but the nice thing is I
remember what that's like and and so I
can you know I never complain about oh I
only have a week to write this article
because I remember when I had to do it
in a day you know so a week is like a
luxury but again though this is a big
difference from academia where you have
all the time in the world to write your
article well maybe not to see all the
time but but you can do it sort of on
your own schedule but in journalism
you're on somebody else's schedule now
the important thing is thinking about
the audience so what do they understand
what are they interested in so so the
key there sort of a shift in the balance
of power when you go from academia to
popular writing so in academia the
writer is the one who served in the
position of power you know you're you're
the person who's proved this theorem and
the reader wants to know it so you sort
of have the power and you know you can
write anything in there they've got to
read through it and try to make sense of
it but in popular writing it's the other
way around the reader has the power he
can turn the page and then you know your
voice is silent then you know you can't
say anything more to them so you have to
write away get him interested
convince him or her that this is
something that he or she wants to read
about and so so you have to think about
what what's the audience interested in
and also explain things on a level that
they'll understand
okay mentioned earlier telling stories
not not just facts now you can put facts
in there but you do it in the context of
a story the importance at the beginning
journalists have even called the
beginning of an article the lead and
they misspelled lead so I don't know how
that that came about but anyhow the lead
of the story is is where you hook the
reader in and if you don't have a good
lead then you know you lose them so in a
newspaper article the lead is the first
paragraph in a magazine article it might
be the first three or four or five
paragraphs but you might find it
interesting you know if you didn't know
this before next time you pick up a
popular magazine take a look at the
leads in the articles because that's
what the arc author will really
concentrate on and you'll find that the
first three or four paragraphs usually
tells a really exciting story or puts
you in the midst of the action you know
does something to get you interested in
this and that's called the lead and then
usually somewhere four or five
paragraphs in there's something called
the nut paragraph or the nut graph which
in one paragraph succinctly summarizes
what the main point of the article is
going to be so you have a lead you have
a nut graph and then you sort of start
giving background and so forth so you'd
be amazed at how many popular science
articles follow this formula another
thing I learned was to bring in
interviews in quotes so journalists
always like what to interview not just
one person but several people you know
so the person who did the work but also
other experts and see what they think
about it okay and then you work their
quotes into the into the article so
again that's really different from
academic art articles where you don't
quote people so much but good quotes can
really liven up a piece because it
brings in another voice you know
it's not just you saying these things
it's it's this person and sometimes
they'll say things really colorfully so
but you don't want to use a quote that's
this super boring you know like if the
quote just says something that could
have been written down you know in a
regular sentence then then forget it but
the quote has some personality behind it
then that's that's really what you're
looking for and writing about things you
aren't an expert in is another big
change when you're writing through the
public when you're a journalist you you
can't be an expert on everything you
have to be a quick study
so you learn what you can you try to
learn enough to write the main idea and
you may not understand every little
detail but you want to convey the main
idea and the last one allow yourself to
be edited this is so different in
journalism you your work is always
edited so in academia and that's so much
next email you write an article you send
it to a journal editor but he doesn't
really line at it and change the wording
and and cut out the section and stuff
like that
the referees made may suggest doing
stuff like that not so much the editor
so the editor plays a much greater role
in journalism and if if you are really
attached to your words and hate having
and having anyone change him then you
probably wouldn't wouldn't like being a
journalist so okay so just wanted to say
a little bit about my books probably not
much but my first book was called the
big splat this was a good example of
writing about something I'm not an
expert in so I'm ever took a course in
planetary science or geology and my
entire academic career and yet that's
what my first book was on the reason was
that I I went to a conference on the
origin of the earth and the moon in 1998
and I was the only press person at the
conference and I was amazed that there
was nearly almost unanimous consensus of
the people the scientists there on how
the moon had formed namely this giant
impact hypothesis
I'll use the laser pointer their giant
impact on us okay so you're trying to
know what that is read the book but
anyway but you can see what the
hypothesis from the picture so anyway so
this really startled me because we spent
twenty five thousand billion dollars as
a country sending astronauts to the moon
and we did it for many reasons but the
number one scientific question on the
agenda was to figure out where the moon
came from and lo and behold the sciences
have answered this to their satisfaction
and no one ever bothered to tell the
public about that and so I thought wow
someone really needs to write a book
about this and it took me about a year
actually to decide that someone meant me
but I finally did and and it ended up
being this book yeah okay so let me go
on I have one of the interesting things
about that book was I actually led to me
getting on TV there was a show on the
History Channel called the universe that
aired for I think they had four seasons
maybe and they invited me on for a
couple episodes about the moon because
they saw they looked up books about the
moon and have an iBook so this was
really interesting for me because it
made me realize that the way that most
people get their science after they've
done a school is through the TV and so
so if you're communicating science to
the public
communicating through the TV is an
incredibly important medium now it's not
one that I'm really experienced with a
traditional writer but I realized after
doing this that in some ways writing a
book is an audition for appearing on TV
and you you might tend to look down your
nose at the TV and say well it's it's
not as literary not as you know hi mind
that is writing books but it reaches so
many more people now my book may be
reached 8,000 people that's how many
copies it sold it probably reached mark
as it went to libraries but but half a
million people watch this TV show and so
I can guarantee you that
people found out about the giant impact
theory this way then from my book so so
if any of you want to get on TV I'd
really strongly encourage you I don't
have any magic you know magic way to do
it except to write a book and then
hopefully they'll find you okay second
book was called the universe in zero
words not the best title because it's
actually a book about math but the the
idea is that it's about formulas history
of 24 great formulas formulas don't have
any words in them so therefore zero
words
so unfortunately not mathematicians
don't get the joke which is why it's not
a great title but anyway after my first
book I felt guilty because I'd written
the book not about math and I really did
want to write about math sometimes so so
this was my attempt to write a book
about math and finally that brings to
this year my third book was published
and this was different this is a joint
book with you day of pearl who's a
computer scientist at UCLA it's called
the book of Y and I will next month in
July I'll give a a reading of this the
there's a copy of the book upstairs in
the library on the third floor I'll put
it back after this is over but anyway if
any of you are interested I'll have a
longer lecture on it next month so
basically your daya as I said here you
daya has spent his career working out a
mathematical theory of causality that
enables you to address causation
questions such as does smoking caused
cancer does co2 cause global warming any
question where you have data and you
want to get causation out of that data
statistics has tended to avoid that with
you know very you know very intensely
they it's really we call it a taboo
you're not allowed to talk about
causation unless you do a randomized
controlled trial and one of your data's
main points is that that's not true so
there are situations where you can talk
about causation you have to make some
assumptions
the assumptions are conveyed using
causal diagrams which are very simple to
understand and once you have them you're
you're perfectly justified in in drawing
causal conclusions from your data and in
fact the causal diagrams will tell you
how to draw those conclusions so anyway
that's a very short overview I'll say a
lot part about the book next month and
you could meet more if you want we wrote
an article for The Wall Street Journal
and there's also an interview of you
daya in the Atlantic online and a review
of our book in the New York Times which
came out last week ok so that's enough
about me actually it's too much about me
so let's start talking about what this
means for you all ok so so when we talk
about communicating with the public
science to the public there's different
ways of doing that so path one would be
the path I took actually changing
careers and becoming a writer or you
know communicator I mean could do radio
TV whatever okay so so here are some
things to think about if you're ever
thinking about doing that so obviously
you need to know like to write and do
you like need to like to talk with
people because you know you're going to
be that's the way you learn about things
you know I do like to read when I write
articles about science I do like to read
the original research but you know I'll
kind of skim through try to get the main
points but the way I really learn this
stuff is through talking with people so
I'm good at listening can you make a
deadline are you willing to have your
words mangled so hopefully they won't be
mangled too often anyway so these are
some things that might indicate that
you'd be a good fit for writing but to
be realistic I know most of you aren't
going to do that that's I mean it's
first of all it's scary changing careers
and so fortunately you can also
communicate about science and still be a
scientist in fact I would hope there
would be more people doing that
and the future and so this is something
I'd really like to encourage any or all
of you to do so I would say I love this
I said get tenure first that's not my
ironclad rule if you're really motivated
to write a book about for the public do
it even before you have tenure but but
it's riskier obviously because you're
you know your colleagues are gonna
wonder what why you're wasting time on
that and you'll have to tell them you're
not wasting time but anyway there are a
number of great role models here these
are mathematicians because I'm more
attuned to mathematics so these are all
good math writers Keith Devlin Steven
Strogatz who've written books that sold
well and are still academics so I think
that being an active being an expert
actually gives you an inside track for
writing a book publishers are interested
in something they call a platform which
means sort of your qualifications to
talk about the subject and now so if
you're a professor in the subject you've
got a ready-made platform people will
believe you mostly okay all right so so
I think that if you're interested in
writing books this is a good way to do
it for for writing shorter shorter form
things newspapers and magazines I think
that being in academia is not
necessarily an advantage and in fact
really what's more important for those
is understanding some of the rules of
journalism that I've told you about
understanding the importance of the lead
you know understanding that you're
telling a story etc so if you can do
those if you understand those things
then you know you might be able to
succeed in writing for newspapers or
magazines and I certainly like to
encourage you to try but just be aware
that you know pitching articles to
magazines you're going to have quite a
few failures before you have successes
so it's different ballgame from the
academic world I think an ideal
situation might be to if you could man
to write a regular column in some
publication or a blog course blogging is
this new you know this new Avenue that's
opened up thanks to the Internet and and
that's a great way to build a platform
to build you know an audience of people
who like you're reading they're like
reading your work and might be
interested in a book then third path now
realistically I understand that most
scientists aren't even going to want to
spend a large part of their time
communicating with the public because
it's it's hard and it's not all that
valued by the disciplines so but even so
you'll still you still should think
about how do you communicate your
research and how do you publicize your
work and publicize what's going on in
your field I think some scientists
science says do this really well physics
and astronomy I think are good at
conveying their results but mathematics
not so much and I don't know where
computer science fits in that spectrum
so one of the important things if you're
at a university you have a public
information office and they are eager to
find out what's going on in your
department in every department but
including yours
and so they would love it if you went to
them and said hey I've just proven this
new theorem or I've just done this great
experiment and and they will be glad to
help you turn that into a press release
or maybe they'll want to write articles
on the University website or other
publications so so this is a great way
to to reach out to the public and I
think that you know the more you do it
the more you'll enjoy it so if they if
they write a press release then what
might happen then is that someone from a
newspaper or magazine or something will
want to talk with you and so that's the
the next thing and that's where
understanding what the press is looking
for will be a big advantage to you
because if you know that they there they
want stories and you know that they want
simple analogies and they want you to
relate your work to people's everyday
lives or to her
fence then you're going to give them a
good interview and if you give them a
good interview the article will be a
good article so so these are some of the
things I've gone over here so if you are
going to talk with a reporter I would
suggest first of all trying to make up
you know make a quick 5 minute version
of what you want to convey what your
what your basic message is the elevator
version it might help to prepare a list
of talking points now maybe five six or
seven things that you'd like to bring up
in the interview and if the reporter
doesn't ask about them you know you
might bring them up yourself that's
that's perfectly okay so if you aren't
prepared in advance you can do that and
then as they've said over and over think
about telling stories not facts and any
story that has some human interest
behind it will be great for the reporter
and you know you'll find those go into
the article really quickly so if you're
good storyteller you know use that
relating your subject to current events
is is helpful also you know this one may
seem minor but actually reporter is
usually for magazines at least usually
have to also find or plan the art for
the article as well the magazine may
have an art department but not
necessarily and if you can
anyway if you can provide some good art
good illustrations that will give the
the journalist something to run with and
so there'll be don't usually be very
happy if you can do that and one day I
put at the bottom here is if you're
talking with reporter you can good to
realize that you can go off the record
sometimes if you want to say something
that's not for publication and they will
usually honor that then another thing
you can ask about is is whether you'll
get to see the article before it appears
in print now if it's a if it's a large
newspaper or magazine you probably will
not be able to the answer is going to be
no and so be prepared for that it
doesn't mean that they're trying to hide
anything from you it's
that journalist walk work on a very
quick time schedule and they just may
not have the time between the final edit
between the edit you know between his
article and the final edit for him to
run it by you but hey you can ask and I
do
I personally if if the publication
allows it I always let people see any
direct quotes you know so if I'm going
to say you know Peter said the moon is
made of green cheese then I will always
show that to Peter before before it gets
into in the print not all reporters do
that that you can at least ask them okay
so so finally this is my yes yeah so if
there's something that could be you know
if there's something about that chess
game that that just made this idea pop
into your head that could be a really
cool thing or you know maybe you saw a
movie and and and that you know inspired
you somehow so people are interested in
in in the human side of the scientists
they want to see that the science
scientist is a human and so yeah that's
that's exactly what I'm talking about
and it can be sometimes you could tell
jokes you know if there's a there's some
joke or anecdote that's you know common
in the field that might also be
something
yes
okay so yeah so here's conclude with I
don't know if any of this would be
controversial or not but so some advice
on getting science out there better one
is first of all providing information to
grad students on non-traditional careers
like journalism okay so when I as a grad
student I certainly never had any idea
you could make a living as a as a math
writer or science writer so provide
incentives for popular writing in
particular I look at the third thing
here I would like to see in promotion
and tenure decisions a newspaper
magazine article count the same as a
research article and that may fly in the
face of academic tradition but but it's
a lot of work to write a good popular
article and I think that should be
should be recommended and should be
recognized and people who take the time
to do it well instead of having their
colleagues say you know he's you know
running after the press or he just you
know whatever what he's wasting time
talking with the press they should
appreciate it because you know any
publicity is good publicity for the
whole field so so you're really doing a
service not just for your own research
but also for the field if you do popular
articles alright and also I think you
might be yes go ahead question is if you
think about
looking at a research article there's no
we don't just say helped up Norway that
what was the intellectual contribution
how the insight added or some place how
does one think about that the context of
a magazine article or a popular book
yeah well I think the is it's really
there just has to be an attitude that if
you are conveying something about
mathematics computer science to the
public then that's a big service to the
community and so this is for how to how
exactly to wait it you know so I can't
you know I can't provide any formulas or
anything but but just just being valuing
this saying that this is important and
it's equally as important as doing the
research because this is the public is
paying the public is the one that the
pays for the universities whether it's
through taxes or through you know
tuition or whatever and so they have a
right to know what's going on so yeah
yes yeah on that's notes probably
realizes over the last ten years
outreach has become more and more
important totally a part of explaining
your your information and research and
the meaning at all that exactly you know
I don't know what his situation is like
in computer science but I've looked at a
lot of the NSF grants I sometimes get
story ideas actually by by looking at
grants awarded I don't think many other
reporters have thought of this but it's
usually someone's got a grant they've
actually done a large part of the work
already and so it's a good way to kind
of see what's coming up you know but
anyway to the point you made when you
look at the outreach part in in the math
grants you know you you can tell there's
a paragraph there that's supposed to
explain to the public what they're doing
and mathematicians have no clue how to
write those paragraphs it's really sad
so I've given you some clues here so
yeah I don't think of you know some
divine inspiration or anything is you
know my job part of my job is to try to
explain what's going on in words that
the the general public can understand
cuz mathematicians and computer
scientists use you know different words
there's more common at a higher level
but I think it's great practice it's it
maybe even good for you as a researcher
to have the experience of saying what it
is in layman's terms that you've done I
think that might actually help you
understand the ideas better and my
co-author you do pearl on this book said
says this in his in the preface he says
that he was surprised at how thinking
about
his work you know the Buccos Aldi how to
explain it to the public has really made
him understand things that he didn't
before so so I think it's not just a
bird and to talk to the public but is
actually something that that that may
improve you know your research or you
know at least give you a different
perspective on it yeah so Wow
that's okay so AI is it's a little bit
out of my domain of expertise of course
but it's it is something that's really
hot in the news right now and your day
and I noticed this very much with our
book that you know we were asked to
write an op-ed for The Wall Street
Journal about the themes in our book and
what they and I actually gave them for
possible topics for the op-ed and the
one that they wanted was they I want so
that's that's or in the news right now
and so so you do yeah you do kind of
have to realize that news comes in
cycles and reporters will all be
interested in in one one sort of thing
for a while and then maybe a couple
years they'll be interested in something
else and that's part of what makes an
articles sellable so right now articles
on AI are just really easy to sell
that's for the second part about getting
things from the preprint servers that's
a really good question and I think that
most reporters traditionally have gotten
their ideas from press releases but they
are certainly getting more and more
clued into the existence of the archive
and and in fast-moving subjects like
physics and computer science and stuff
they you know they're realizing that
that's kind of where the action is but
but don't have any real good way of
assessing quality control I don't really
know a good solution to that as I said
you know journalism isn't imperfect
imperfect thing and a it even if it's
about some quality result it may not be
you know technically perfectly hundred
percent correct and then the other way
in which journalism can get it wrong is
by taking things that are not really
high quality work and making them seem
more important than they are so it's it
it's unfortunately it's not a science we
do the best we can questions so many of
the things that you've said and how do
you communicate this to each and all
public I think also applies to
scientists if this state was in their
own field now they hold the conference
like the joint mathematics meeting like
15 minutes 15 minutes they don't have to
give all the details of the proof what
they have to do is make it sound
interesting enough it wants to go and
read their paper and they doing that I
mean half the stuff that you say yeah
story have the motivation behind it you
know just make it so exciting people
want to go on that's right yeah the
these dirty tricks I'm telling you about
well you know because even your academic
audiences are human and the things that
interest humans will interest them too
you dare my co-author had another
amusing comment on this so we were
talking about this just a week or two
ago he said it's so surprising to him
that to get his colleagues to understand
what he's been doing he had to go to the
public he had to go behind their back to
the public and and I wrote him back well
if you went behind their back it's only
because they've been facing away from
the public so it's not going about how
their back you're going to the people
you ought to be going to and but it is
funny that by writing this popular book
all of a sudden some of his colleagues
are unjust you know they're they
suddenly understand what he's been doing
and they say oh that's really neat so
yeah so the rewards are really terrific
for doing this and so as he said the
same the same principles will work for
talking with your
with your peers as well absolutely okay
yeah Christian so the way is so most of
the advice that you gave was advice for
becoming like the most successful so if
somehow interest is not so much how
myself to my community will have
positive changes would you give the same
advice like fight what is popular and
well I think that the the most important
thing is to value communicating with the
public you know so too if you if you get
something that's really exciting in your
work or if you hear about it in somebody
else's work even think about talking
about it you know talk about with your
friends and maybe even you know go
little one step farther especially if
it's your own work like I said talk with
the the university public relations
office and you know I think those are
things that don't require you to commit
yourself to a whole different career or
to being like a part-time writer you
know in addition to being a university
professor I just think that when when
something exciting comes along it's you
know you know you either do it yourself
or at least value the people who are
trying to to communicate it to the
public so if you know if you have a
colleague in your department who is
doing work of this sort you know then
when they come up for tenure they come
up for promotion gives them credit for
that because that's really helping
everybody yeah so so it doesn't
necessarily mean need to be a career
change but I think an attitude change is
a smaller step you can make that that
you know everyone has that change of
attitude of being
yeah oh that's that's a big one yeah
okay okay so so yeah it's interesting
that my some of my biggest conflicts
with sources have been over credit you
know so the thing yeah so journalists
really do want to when you tell a story
you want to have a protagonist so it
just works easier that way now you could
have two or three protagonists but that
already makes it a more complicated
story you know I've got to explain how
he got interested in the how he got
interested and how did you know who did
what and stuff like that maybe a really
good story and I I really actually I
like that kind of story and and and I
share your frustration about that
I think journalists probably do are a
little too attached to the lone genius
and don't appreciate the collaborative
nature of everything in science as much
as they should but on your side you
should recognize that science that the
journalist is trying to tell a good
story and that maybe not every person on
this 15 author paper is going to get
recognized in this story you know yeah
well yeah so you can you know so so it
may be that you'll have to emphasize two
or three and and but make it clear to
the journalist what did those be each of
those people do what do they bring to it
that you know the that really made this
collaboration work
like accidentally have a good story
about how we met and how the project
started so it seems like yeah and that
gets to what Andres was asking about you
know like you know if you had the idea
for this article about playing a chess
game you know even though it's silly
that's a great human interesting and
similarly how you how you met each other
especially there's some unusual way that
happened there are some you know
interesting story about how happened
absolutely that's the sort of thing that
the journalist will like
you mentioned books you mentioned blogs
you mentioned TV yeah what about YouTube
YouTube wow yeah that's right yeah yeah
that's right
Brady Haran yeah yeah oh yeah this video
up there on numberphile yeah at the end
of the interview had made a very stupid
joke and then I was absolutely
flabbergasted when I saw the YouTube
video he put together because he put it
up front what was in three days get
300,000 hits it's amazing well that's
true you know I would need to update
this because yeah I didn't think about
YouTube but I love numberphile yeah
what what he does is great and so yeah
and I I don't know if you know appearing
in a YouTube video should also be
considered as you know when you come up
for tenure and stuff but that I think so
I think it should so yeah this is
fantastic that those opportunities are
there and and it kind of goes along with
what I said about the TV that you know
you write a book for a few thousand
people you go on TV and you know
millions of people see it that's
okay so the last thing I want to mention
is so for this program I would like to
contribute something as you know I'm
here in part to get ideas to learn about
quantum computation and maybe I can
write articles in the future about them
but I'd like to offer you some some
service too and so one thing I'd like to
offer is if any of you would be
interested in writing a piece on your
work I would be glad to take a look at
it
critique it and it is if you want and
then another thing which that's that
first thing has been done by previous
journalists in residence here another
idea that we hasn't been done before is
to have practice interviews so so I can
if you're interested in this we could
sit down and I can interview you for a
half hour an hour on your work on
something you'd like to to to talk about
and then I could write a rough draft of
an article about that and then you could
read that in critique it did I you know
what did I get right whether I get wrong
and then I could also critique you as to
you know what could you have done better
and you interview and maybe you might be
able to tell even from what I write so
anyway if any of you interested in
either of these things you know writing
some practice articles or doing practice
interviews just come by my office and
you know and let's talk about it yeah so
I'm around for six more weeks though
it's an eight week program so I'm around
for six more weeks and for you know for
the practice interviews if I could do
once a one-week that would be awesome
I don't know you know if the interest is
greater or less than that but that would
be cool and I mentioned this too to
create Kristen and she said that there
is a Simon's Institute blog that sort of
is is inactive right now but but we
could develop these into blog posts too
which I think would benefit the the
Institute
anyway just something for you to think
about so my offices is is 324 342 342 so
just come by and we could talk about it
so thanks for your time and we have tea
coffee and snacks outside another
question the discussion going out there
yeah sure yeah if you want to slide